>>> YOU'RE WATCHING THE GAME
SHOW NETWORK.
REMEMBER HOW RICHARD DAWSON
WOULD KISS ENTIRE FAMILIES?
WELL, YOU DO NOW.
BUT FIRST, IT'S "WORD CRUNCH."
>> WELCOME BACK TO "WORD
CRUNCH."
I'M YOUR HOST, GENE BABY.
SAY HELLO TO OUR CONTESTANTS,
CARA, SHEILA, AND DAVE.
>> HI, THERE.
>> HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> WHOO!
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE GAME IS SIMPLE.
WE'LL SHOW YOU A BUNCH OF
LETTERS, AND THOSE LETTERS, SOME
MAKE WORDS.
FIND THOSE WORDS, YOU GET
POINTS.
AND THOSE POINTS IS MONEY, WOW.
SORRY, FOLKS.
THERE'S A WRITER'S STRIKE SO OUR
SOUND ENGINEER WROTE ALL THIS
HERSELF.
THANKS, CHRIS.
>> YOU GOT IT, BABY, LOVE YA!
>> ALL RIGHT.
CONTESTANTS, LET'S PULL UP OUR
FIRST WORD CRUNCH.
IF YOU SEE A WORD, JUST SHOUT IT
OUT.
AND YOUR TIME STARTS NOW.
>> OH, I SEE "HAPPY."
>> YOU GOT IT.
5 POINTS.
>> I SEE "CAT."
>> GREAT, THAT'S 3 POINTS.
>> I SEE "MOM HOLE."
>> NO, SORRY ABOUT THAT, CARA,
NO POINTS.
BUT THERE'S STILL TIME, KEEP
GUESSING.
>> "DOG."
>> NICE, 3 POINTS FOR DAVE.
>> OH, I'VE GOT ONE, "MOM HOLE."
>> YEAH, AGAIN, CARA, MAYBE STOP
GUESSING "MOM HOLE."
WE CANNOT ACCEPT "MOM HOLE."
>> WHY NOT?
>> WELL, IT'S A FEW REASONS.
FOR ONE, IT'S TWO WORDS.
YOU COULD DO "MOM," AND THEN
AFTER THAT, YOU COULD SAY
"HOLE."
>> BUT I WANT TO CONNECT THEM.
>> WELL, YOU CAN'T.
PLEASE GUESS SOMETHING ELSE.
>> FINE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OH, "MOM HOLE."
>> YES, OH, I TOLD YOU NOT TO
SAY THAT.
>> NO, NO, THE OTHER ONE.
>> WHY ARE THERE TWO?
>> I DON'T KNOW, GENE, THIS
ISN'T MY GAME.
>> OH, OH, I'VE GOT ONE.
I SEE "APPLE."
>> GREAT, 5 POINTS.
>> SO WAIT, LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
SHE SAYS "APPLE," WHICH IS
5 POINTS, AND YOU THINK THAT'S
COOL.
BUT THEN WHEN I SAY "MOM HOLE,"
WHICH IS 7, I GET NOTHING?
THAT DOESN'T SEEM FAIR.
>> WELL, APPLE IS A REAL THING,
SO --
>> SO IS MOM HOLE.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT
IT, BUT THEY'VE GOT THEM.
>> OH, I'VE GOT ANOTHER ONE.
"POTHOLE."
>> OH, GREAT, 7 POINTS.
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> CARA, CARA, RELAX.
>> OKAY, SO IF I HAD SAID
"POTHOLE" THAT WOULD HAVE
COUNTED?
>> YES.
>> OKAY, GREAT.
SO "MOM HOLE."
[ BUZZER ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S JUST GET A NEW PUZZLE UP
HERE.
>> AM I ALLOWED TO GUESS?
>> YES, AS LONG AS IT'S NOT "MOM
HOLE."
>> NO PROBLEM.
"HIM HOLE."
>> NO.
>> "GAY HOLE."
>> WOW, THERE'S A FOUR ON THE
BOARD.
>> "JACKSON HOLE."
>> WHAT?
>> "HOLE FOODS."
"MY HOLE."
>> OKAY.
>> "CORN HOLE."
>> COME ON!
>> AND "MMM HOLE."
>> OKAY, THAT IS NOT "MMM HOLE,"
THAT'S JUST THREE MS AND THEN
"HOLE."
WHAT IS "MMM HOLE"?
>> YOU KNOW, LIKE "MMM, YUMMY,
LIKE I'M EXCITED FOR THAT HOLE."
>> OH, MY GOD.
CHRIS, WHAT IS WITH THESE WORD
SEARCHES?
>> JUST TRYING TO PUT MY SPIN ON
IT, LOVE YA, BABY, MWAH!
>> OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, GUYS,
NEW RULE OF THIS SHOW.
IF YOU SEE "HOLE" ON THE BOARD,
DON'T SAY "HOLE."
WE NO LONGER ACCEPT ANY "HOLE"
>>
>> WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM WITH
MOMS?
>> LET'S GET A NEW PUZZLE AND NO
MORE HOLE STUFF.
I DON'T WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
BUT I SEE PORN.
>> MOM PORN.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM WITH
MOMS?
>> DO YOU SEE ANYTHING ELSE?
>> FRIEND.
>> BEACH.
>> SCISSORING.
>> CLOUD.
>> "WATER."
>> "BALLS."
"LIPS."
"BUTT."
"SLIT.
"BLOW."
"GAG."
"JUICE."
"TITTY."
"HORNY."
AND "TIME."
>> OKAY, WHATEVER.
I DON'T EVEN CARE.
FINE.
LET'S DO THE LAST PUZZLE.
OH, NO.
>> I DO, I SEE ONE.
>> YEAH.
YEAH, I'M SURE YOU DO.
>> WELL, IS IT OKAY IF I SAY IT?
>> YEAH, JUST DO IT, WHATEVER.
>> "BEE."
>> THAT IS -- THAT'S -- I'M
SORRY, THAT'S DUMB.
>> PLEASE DON'T PICK IT UP FOR
ANOTHER SEASON.
GOODNIGHT.